mike give us the next story okay so cnn
reports one homeowner in south lake
tahoe got a fun springtime surprise
they'd be hearing a purring sound under
the floorboards for months turns out
there were bears
under their house wow a full family of
bears a mama bear and four baby cubs
it's so adorable
experts say the homeowner was probably
hearing the bears cozy hibernation
sounds
snoring breathing nursing maybe some
rolling around the bears have safely
returned to the forest good ending my
sister patty and i
years ago we went to alaska into this
place called catman national park you go
to bear orientation when you show up and
they teach you if you ever see a bear
what to do supposed to clap yeah clap
you go i'm right here bear i'm right
here i'm mike you're a bear you know
let's make noise right really so where i
was fly fishing with this guide and my
sister patty and i hear my sister patty
go mike and i look around there's a bear
about probably 25 feet from my yeah i
know it was wild and i was so scared i
froze up and then the guide
now step up first i'm going to explain
this but it's like the guide snapped and
actually sprinted at the bear and he
goes yeah
yeah
yeah
and the bear just walked away like i'm a
bear etc and i was so relieved that my
sister didn't get eaten by the bear but
then i was a little mad because i was
like you know you didn't tell me about
the yacht plan yeah yeah you told me to
go right here man
i'm right here
okay and finally oh my gosh uh we have a
big wedding kerfuffle out of the uk ooh
mike i think this one's gonna speak to
you this comes from the mirror the
groomsman got into hot water with the
bride because he secretly ordered pizza
to the parking lot
veggies and salad at the reception were
not cutting it he needed a little more
fuel so he ordered pizza to his car
covertly but unfortunately the other
guest joins in and when the bride caught
the grim himself biting into a cheesy
slice she lost it
this is you know bridal dresses flying
pizza is a solution for for most things
totally
totally especially on drew's news a
pizza pillow i
i know we do have plates out here it's
weird i don't know why why do we have
plates out here
oh my gosh oh my gosh
[Applause]
i'm doing the right thing by serving you
guys first that's love when i show up on
a talk show and you serve me pizza i
know i have a problem
[Laughter]
no you gotta figure it out we're just
that awesome show that wants to like
pizza deliver
you proud i'm very proud of you well
mike for bigly i get more mike on his
podcast mike burbigly is working it out
and i'm saying all of this with pizza in
my mouth to honor your love of pizza and
he has a solo show the old man and the
pool and it is coming to chicago and l.a
so check the website for tickets i will
be there
[Music]
you